cool so roadog and I just got back from
our three hour run where he literally
like pounded me down the Queen K for
three hours and that it wasn't too bad
the heat was no there's no hot you know
definitely you know needed we worked on
we ran a car GoPro and some salt taps
and we did all right made a couple quick
water stomps but good heat acclamation
nice 3-hour run on the Queen K get ready
for ultraman so we just got back thought
we'd share with you a little post
long-run recovery nutrition so in the
boiler so what we're gonna do is we're
gonna use this contraption which for
those of you who don't know it's called
a Vitamix looks like a blender but it's
actually much more than a blender it's
got like a jet engine on it it will
literally make juice out of anything so
you can put broccoli in there you can
put asparagus in there and just drink it
it's unbelievable so this is like the
staple of my nutrition pre-workout
nutrition and post-workout so normally
we'd come back probably the first thing
we would do is drink some coconut water
which is great for electrolytes although
we don't have any said we're gonna have
to go to the market and get some of that
so we're gonna make do what we got here
we're gonna do a fruit one today so we
got a couple of bananas here we're gonna
throw in here got a couple of oranges
got a lemon all like organic produce
from the farmers market here in Kona
throw a little organic apple juice in
there and we have coconut milk though we
do have coconut milk this stuff is the
bomb that is doesn't know it's delicious
and very nutritious so we're gonna put
some of that in there too well doc
turned me on to that the other day your
stuff is great stuff and see you
wouldn't put a little vague out whole
food optimizer in there great source of
plant-based nutrition thanks Brendan
shops on the brand Rozier plants dog
we're living through you so it's cute
with that
and little Rice Protein we see the fan
of that place yeah actually usually I
would use a Sun warrior but I love that
stuff so much I ran out so I'm Lucy I'm
gonna get in touch with you I got to get
some more some yeah ship some out to us
Lucy and then a little hemp protein to
use a living harvest it's a good stuff
two different kinds of plant-based
protein you gotta make sure you get a
full amino acid profile protein so the
first thing we want to do is get some
good protein in there and also or
replenish our glycogen stores and we
want to get our essential fatty acids -
so I like to use a couple different kind
of oils this is coconut oil put a little
down in there oops a little black seed
oil here what brand is that red just
this kind this is spectrum not
particularly to any kind of brand of
this but I also used the today got EFA
oil essential fatty acid boil but I'm
out of that at the moment so that's a
good product to use squirt of the hemp
oil in there too little almond milk air
oh this is sweet milk the other ones off
oh no where's the olive oil the other
one which by the way is amazing I had
the modesta - right when I walked in the
door and how about a little throw a
little peanut butter organic peanut
butter or almond butter in there so the
cashew butter good rich cashew butter -
and the Vitamix by the way you can make
your own almond milk just by putting
almonds in there and some water actually
is just pretty soon cashews
you some almonds or walnuts it's good to
put that in there and how about a little
spirulina there's so onna on a
post-workout recovery drink we don't do
any chia see - we don't do the maca the
chia seed I usually do pre-workout those
are good
you know beats those are all good
endurance boosters but post-workout the
main thing is we replenishing your
glycogen stores within 30 minutes try
some good protein in there as soon as
you can so you can recover quickly
between working especially when you're
working out twice a bed like we are so
walk three times more three stools
exactly so let's bring this up and see
what we get
and by the way to camp bread that you
bought last night yeah is amazing I had
like four slices of those as soon as I
walked in the door
there we go all right let me hold back
Jason give that a hit what do you think
take time right ready to God and doing a
two-hour run now yeah another three-hour
run all right
absolutely amazing all right so what I
think is amazing is how how God brought
us together and like I haven't had red
meat 1 2 years but I still I still have
fish because I always was worried about
the protein mm-hmm and I never really
knew what the combination was to get the
proper protein as you know as an
endurance athlete protein is key mm-hmm
and so protein is key but there's also I
think a lot of misunderstanding about
the amount of protein you need I think
that in general most people probably ate
too much protein and of course protein
is important you got to get it in but
you got to make sure you get a full
amino profile right so that you're
rebuilding your muscles properly but you
know it's a myth that you need animal
protein to to make it happen what about
those people out there say you can't get
all that I'm you know branches amino
acid everything from hemp I think that
it's your if you're if you educate
yourself about plant-based nutrition and
plant-based proteins and you're
conscious about you know the meals that
you're preparing that you're gonna be
fine you do have to take a little bit
more care and pay attention a little bit
more about what you're eating but if
you're eating lots of fruits and
vegetables all different colors and
you're eating them every day I think
you're gonna be ok so you know normally
even I wouldn't even supplement with
extra protein but when we're working out
so much we go make sure
we're getting what we need right okay
awesome Hey we just wanted to uh we're
gonna bring you into our world for about
the next three weeks we're gonna bring
you into our little world for about the
next two weeks leading up to Ultraman
2009 World Championships rich Rahl was
kind enough to come out here and get
acclimated for the next three weeks
while we lead into this this brutal race
but uh amazing man amazing spirit and
we're gonna go plant strong for the next
three weeks huh
right on we're gonna do a little laughs
I'm gonna change pace so hey thanks for
stopping by god bless and we'll see you
guys soon
all right just want to thank Jason for
opening up his home to me so I could
come out to cone a little bit early and
get ready for Ultraman so we're gonna
we're getting ready to give it our best
shot so plant strong we'll be back in
touch soon take it easy peace